because if you're in the game of being
around in 10 years you have to
understand what's coming up the ranks
these are 15 17 19 year olds that aren't
lazy that are not entitled that are not
soft they have options this is not about
they don't want to work this is about
i'm 16 and i make 250 000 a year on
youtube ads this is i'm 22 and i could
just do makeup on tick tock and make 110
000 a year sorry mom i don't want to go
work at some [ __ ] place for forty
five thousand a year this is not they're
soft this is they're smart
you've got your perspective
i just wanna be happy don't you want to
be happy
[Music]
uh it's really fun to be back on stage
um just starting to get back on the road
i think this is my fourth talk since uh
covid so really excited to be with you
and super excited to be with you because
when i think about this industry and the
opportunities within it
what's going on in the marketplace right
now in most parts of the country and
then
for me what's kind of going on at a
global level
with human beings and their relationship
with technology and the opportunities
that exist it's interesting to be here
because obviously this brand
is more aggressive
than so many other entities from a
technology standpoint in this space
which really kind of connects for me
because my background
really does sit
in the cross-sections of technology or
personal brand
small business you know regional
business so
i was giving a lot of thought to what i
wanted to cover in this talk today and i
think i'm going to break it down into a
couple places
and now with a sixth book coming out uh
it was supposed to be out yesterday
but some of you might have saw i did an
nft
marketing campaign for this book and we
sold 1.2 million copies
so
they couldn't print them fast enough so
we pushed it two weeks thank you
that wasn't a humble brag i didn't need
the class but you're very sweet
it was it was more of setting up the
context of what i just wrote about in 12
and a half but it's actually this is
actually perfect this is luck
i want to basically talk to you about 12
and a half and i want to talk to you
about jab jab jab right hook the 2022
version i think the 2022 landscape of
real estate is extremely fascinating for
me i think the ogs in this room and even
the youngsters may realize because of
kovid we have such unique things to try
to figure out of what is this market
right whether it's growth or decline or
how there's just so many unique dynamics
that a global pandemic created that are
unusual to look at in even a 50 or 100
year window so i think we can all
imagine and i'm sure this is what you
spend a ton of your time on is like well
what's the market really going to be
like
right and and to me the thing that i've
been most passionate about in my career
and i think i'm most proud of
25 years into operating is that
regardless of what the market has been
i've been able to be successful the
market threw me for a loop for my
premium wine business that focused on
wall street in 2001 when 911 happened
and that entire ecosystem
literally
was devastated and so i had to adjust to
that the market was incredibly difficult
to navigate in 2008 and nine with the
recession and again i was very much in
the premium wine business
kind of hard to sell 800 bottles of wine
when the entire economy is collapsing
and i was starting vayner media so that
was super interesting 09
and
and onwards and onwards at onwards and
we will all go through that and then
obviously you know
for this market after he got off the
initial hump there was incredible
opportunity in real estate with covid
not so much for my business
vayner got very caught because we were
not small enough or not big enough for
any government support so i got zero
dollars and zero cents to navigate the
last 18 months with my companies
uh which to be very transparent is the
best
you know um i uh people people
love capitalism and entrepreneurship but
when it gets super hard they always want
the government's help and i laugh at
that [ __ ]
um
yeah
please don't give me that affirmation
because i'll spend 40 minutes on this
subject matter um
[Music]
i think a lot about the people in this
audience because i think about context i
think about why would you even want to
be associated with this company what is
the value prop what are you doing like
why are you doing that versus something
else a competitor of theirs or doing it
yourself
that's why i'm so passionate about jab
jab right hook
this company from afar i haven't really
triple checked under the hood so i'm
speaking in headline reading from a
technology standpoint is clearly
committed and because i know enough
about the competitive landscape from a
technology standpoint which is almost
non-existent i'm going to make
assumptions that they're winning for you
on that moat
what i also know back to what i the joke
i just made about the government helping
is
if you are not the queen and the king of
your domain of brand building and
marketing
nobody's gonna help you
no matter how much they try no matter
how much tom ferry no matter how much
you watch my content it doesn't matter
if you are not actually actually i'm
thrilled to hear the uh framework for
this talk or 2022.
in a no excuses way it's incredibly
important we spend a lot of time on what
i want to talk to you about
if you signed up for this company or any
other company for that matter and you
believe that is the engine to your
marketing
and your brand building you're in for a
rude awakening it's just not gonna
happen
and i don't say that as a negative i
think there are macro things this logo
and seven or eight others in this space
do carry clout when you put it over your
name and you are more considered in your
local market like that i believe i
believe in the macro brand
but my curiosity and what i'm focused on
and as i look at this room and think
about this brand in this ecosystem so
i'm making assumptions of a lot of the
people that decided to jump on board
here
what excites me is it speaks to a level
of
innovation and ambition that is a
competitive advantage at least for me
looking at it from afar against your
competitive set like if you jump if
you're here
you're slightly different
in my opinion that you chose this brand
than the other options you could have
had
don't clap yet
because it's because this is what i want
to talk about because it could be epic
or it could actually be the
vulnerability of 2022 which is why i
want to talk to you about it
it could be epic because you're more
innovative you're more progressive
you're this that and the other thing
it could be a vulnerability if you're
over relying on the company's
branding and aggressiveness and are
assuming it's yours
and for all the things i do the majority
of my time is spent listening
my flight to orlando yesterday three
hours just reading 41 different hashtags
and every comment everybody had about it
my flight from orlando to here yesterday
reddit and 4chan
groups and facebook groups to get a
sense i did a ton of homework on many of
you in here and the content that you put
out
it was enjoyable it was enjoyable
because it was affirmation for me once
again of how much people don't
understand social media not as i'm
professor and you stink i mean it
honestly this isn't this is just an
important combo it's not like you don't
get it i get who gives a crap let me
just tell you an observation that is
predicated on the people in here's
content on social
which is the following
the lack of patience
in actually building relationship on
social see my thing with real estate
agents
and firms is really fascinating in real
life
there's actually an incredible level of
patience
and relationship building going on with
the people that win
you're all good to get in there with the
pta
you're awesome at some softball coaching
you're really good at girls night at
with wine at the pizza thing on thursday
you're cultivating
you're romancing
you're flirting
on social
you're like a drunk dude at a bar last
night
slipping a key off of a hello
i got in last night i saw some of you
listen to me
99 of the content in social forget about
real estate the industry you know i have
2 000 people globally we have all sorts
of data scientists nerds that can't even
look you in the face because they only
care about math all the stuff that you
can imagine
and we look at this stuff this is what i
do for a living this is what i do 99 of
the content that is put out on social is
dramatically and inherently selfish
it doesn't land
there's too much
it's just supply and demand if you're
just posting another picture of a
beautiful house there are 73 000 of
those on instagram and linkedin and
twitter
we're not good at it
the variable of success in 2022 in the
real estate industry is being good at it
this is very important there are ogs in
this crowd who have dominated their
local market for 15 years relationship
on relationship on relationship who are
starting to lose market share to
first-year rookies because first-year
rookies know how to make a tick-tock
yeah this is important
and rookies don't get high in yourself
you're doing a lot of dumb [ __ ] too
all right
[Applause]
some of you rookies need to learn the
basics of actually how to do a contract
but we'll get into that later
and this is the point listen to me
i want to help this room because i don't
usually get a full hour usually it's q a
i'm like god damn it an hour keynote how
am i going to fill this i'm like i might
as well go deep so we're going to go
deep
please if you remember anything from
this talk think purple let me explain
what i mean by that
what the reactions and the energies that
just happened is there's this
fascinating thing this is the beautiful
thing about
being a listener and as some of you may
know my sister has entered this business
three years ago so i'm double listening
because i love her more than anything so
i'm paying attention even more there's
this incredible tension
and conversation and just macro energy
of the youth movement versus the ogs
because of technology before it was just
the ogs you had to pay your dues and for
the ogs i have a lot of empathy i had to
pay my dues too like
you don't think i'm mad that i didn't
have the internet and the blockchain
when i was 15 i would have owned the
jets by 19.
but the ogs need to understand you don't
control when timing is you're mad that
these kids have facebook and can speed
it up well guess what your great great
grandmother's mad at you that you had
running water like you know things
like things change it's okay
right so
but what we have to do is the following
i am fascinated
that so many people that are
players in their market
have an advantage of history and
reputation and word of mouth are
allowing the rookies to take up so much
of the attention and the real estate i'm
fascinated by it it comes out of your
audacity
it comes out of your audacity
i understand you're the queen bee of
sacramento
but
technology doesn't care about you
and it's happening and i'm watching it
happen on the flip side for the rooks
you a lot of them are moving too fast
and are relying just on the notion of
social content and are making missteps
on the stake
of the game of sizzle and steak and so
there's a lot going on but the reality
is and everybody knows it here
you can stumble through your first five
six seven eight deals you're gonna learn
that part
how to do it and how to have
partnerships and couple relationships
it's the commodity we can razz on the
rooks of like they stumbled there they
didn't get it there or they missed up
there you were rook too you made those
same things you figured it out they're
gonna figure it out
the people in this room that are putting
their head in the sand that they need to
be putting out stick with me now seven
to 12 pieces of content on social media
a day
uh-huh
if you have basic ambition
the people that have their head in the
sand on that
are going to lose that's the word i'm
going to use what do i mean by lose i
don't mean you're going out of business
the market's hot the world's abundant
nobody's real when you're mad at that
person in town nobody's really taking
your stuff like there's plenty of room
for everybody i mean it's going to chip
away day by day by day
and market share is important especially
when you're in this business and your
market share is quote unquote somewhat
limited
the stakes are extremely high for the
people in this room to actually figure
out how to do social media content
social media content
along with ott netflix hulu are the
dominant consumption tools of our
society
the end
i watch people
spend money
on dumb [ __ ]
because that's what got them there
they're quick
to spend 3k on a billboard because it
makes their ego feel good because they
drive by it
but they won't run three thousand
dollars in ads against localized tick
tock content when the cost of the tick
tock ads are so underpriced it makes me
borderline uncomfortable
and because we've seen this game with
instagram and facebook it's just basic
pattern recognition
and
people want to make assumptions that tic
toc is 12 to 18 year olds when everybody
in here knows that's not true
i love when people are actually on tik
tok themselves but then claim it's not
good for their business because their
age group's not on it yet they're on it
2022 is the single best year
for a real estate agent
and brokerage and team and firm and
brand and compass
because
america's attention
is more on social in 2022 than 2021
and social
creative making the videos and pictures
and the ads are dramatically
underpriced compared to print radio
television outdoor and benches
that one hit
if i
if i could leave with
anything i would leave with a macro
commitment
from the top the mezzanine in this floor
a macro commitment
to
actually deploy the 25 hours of homework
this is what i'm asking for i'm asking
for 25 hours of homework
from you
i'm not looking for you to get motivated
or compelled or potentially open to
doing this and then deciding you're
going to go home and you're going to
hire your 23 year old niece because she
gets this [ __ ]
i need you to get it
you have to understand it because if you
don't you won't know how to judge your
23 year old niece or the person in the
office that does it if you don't
understand it
you don't know how to judge it
the reason
i have so many people reach out to me
and say gary this doesn't work
is because they don't know how to do it
they don't know how to judge it you know
what doesn't work for me a screwdriver
i'm serious
give me a hammer and a screwdriver and i
can't do that much with it
i'm not overtly handy
and so what people do is they blame the
tools and the opportunity but not
themselves and their capability
what i'm looking for is 25 hours
of actual homework how do you post a
tick tock ad enter on google
yeah people like gary so how do i do
this i'm like go to google
i know so much now
google
it's free
right oh geez remember we had to go to
the encyclopedia britannica
25 hours of homework so that you
can post seven times a day on social
media in 2022
who has even a glimpse of potentially
wanting to do that raise your hand
thank you
not a very good number but i appreciate
the self-awareness
now let's talk about self-awareness
let's talk about self-awareness
and let's talk about what i'm talking
about now because it's a pretty
aggressive jump to go to seven posts a
day versus once a week
right i'm empathetic and by the way
let me be very candace with this
audience
i could care less if you do it
i don't know who you are and i actually
don't care about you
so
i don't have any feelings or needs of
you accomplishing this i genuinely love
when i get the email from somebody in
here eight months from now saying i
cannot believe this is working the way
it is thank you so much that i get a
huge high on but in real talk
i'm leaving in 45 minutes
i'm saying this to be historically
correct for my own content that i'm
gonna put out
drock where are you
hey drock right so
this talk is for me
if you're interested in getting the
collateral benefit of it
i really need you to get serious about
this before you say no
the biggest issue in entrepreneurship in
business and just in life in general is
this infatuation with no versus maybe
this infatuation with no
this concept of gary i've already tried
we did that two years ago it didn't
really work i didn't get enough leads
this infatuation with well i'm
comfortable on facebook but i don't like
this tick tock thing i'm trying to get
my daughter off of it what do i need it
for this that any other thing
the game of self-awareness is incredibly
important in what i'm about to say for
example i've been talking about for the
last three years about linkedin quite a
bit linkedin about five years ago really
converted and i see by some head nods
you know where i'm going it went from a
tool that we would use to recruit or
just spam people on email to a social
network for all intensive purposes
content content content by show of hands
how many people here consume content on
linkedin raise your hands raise it high
i want everybody to see it higher
thank you for the likes this is awesome
one more time hi
look how many people are consuming
content on linkedin thank you everybody
what what i love about linkedin is it
gives people options in here let me
explain
linkedin is incredibly effective with
just the written word
linkedin is incredibly effective with
just the written word i know that a lot
of people in this room even though this
is your profession
are
skewing more introverted aren't
interested
in being on camera are insecure
about certain aspects the way they talk
the sound of their voice the way they
look i'm empathetic to that that's real
that's very real to the conversation i'm
having with you
however if this audience understood
how many people are actually getting
leads from written words on linkedin it
would be a different conversation
this is why i talk about self-awareness
you have to understand how you like to
communicate
some people have the gift of gab to do
it on video and the comfort
others really genuinely struggle with
that but actually can talk and don't
realize that they can just hit the memo
button on their iphone
record it save it and post the audio
there is no rules for content creation
the rules are very simple be self-aware
of what you
are good at or enjoy so that you can
actually achieve the amount of output
and then most importantly what i started
with
this industry
has to find a better way to bring value
than just
telling people about the listing
the jab jab jab of right hook was very
simple
talk about other things
and then it's unbelievably okay once
you've built up equity to ask
aka post the listing you will close the
listing your open house will be more
attended if you've done a phenomenal job
in actually bringing some level of value
in your feeds the problem is everybody
goes so literal
i'm a real estate entity in this feed
i'm going to talk about real estate
what people don't realize is all the
strengths that so many of you have in
the real world
are the strengths that you can have in
content
the thing that i really want to
challenge this audience to think about
is if you love golf or cooking
or fishing
that that should be a core component of
your content strategy you can't post
seven times a day if the only thing you
want to talk about is your listing
or joining your team
you can when you decide to be in you
know an actual human being
so when we think through this framework
of how we provide value
we need to understand this now what gets
really interesting for me
is the no versus the maybe let me
explain
tick-tock right this second
is a marketing phenomenon
you can literally tonight because you
thought this talk made some sense to you
download tick tock for the first time
how many people here do not have a tick
tock account raise your hand
stand up
stand up
stand up
stand up
stand up if you do not have a tick tock
let's see it lights up there i got it
good all right
first
first
no keep standing back up back up dude
thank you
first
let's clap it up for these patriots
you could sit
i can't believe i can't believe you do
not have a tick tock after 15 years of
this
unacceptable we'll talk after the show
let me tell you what's so cool about
this for me this is wild i'm gonna go
this is what's fun about having an hour
for the ones that stood that are
compelled out of curiosity to maybe make
a play
i want you to create a tick tock account
after this talk tonight this evening
when you create your account
i want you to put your photo in i prefer
it not be one of those
atrocious linkedin pictures all of you
have
be human
and in the bio
you explain who you are
including the real estate part but not
only
i then want you to put in the link the
default link a link that is directly to
your business
right whatever your business best link
is
then i want your first tick tock to be
something outrageously simple
the glass of wine you're drinking the
person you're with
the meal you're having something
whatever
here is what is remarkable about
tick-tock that we have not seen in the
last 20 years
tick-tock unlike every other platform
is built actually excuse me tick-tock
like tumblr years ago
some memories
is built on the interest graph not on
the social graph
you're not getting in your feed who your
friends are or who your friends or
friends are you're getting in the feed
things that you like
so if people like football and wine and
jokes that's what their feed is the
reason tick tock's doing so well
is people are getting posts they want
things they're interested in
and so the interest graph is amazing
because unlike the social graph where
all of you remember when you went on
twitter or facebook or instagram and you
posted and you had to like text your
four friends and ask them to like it
because you felt so bad about yourself
i know how humans roll
on tick tock and this is what's so
bananas about it and this will go away
because it's all supply and demand of
attention
and as more ads are being run on tick
tock and more people are producing
content so this is all the same story
these gray hairs come in handy i'm now
on not intuition i'm here now on pattern
recognition
what's amazing
about tik tock is that there's somebody
in this room who literally right now
does not have
a tick tock account
is going to post something
ridiculous
and is going to have 800 000 people see
the video and one of them emailed them
for a lead
that's right what's crazy melissa
and i appreciate your no
is and i know like you're saying it from
the like that's that's why i'm pumped
that's why i'm saying it right now
what's so wild is um the only other time
we saw anything remotely like this
was early early early facebook fan pages
2011
where you would post something and you'd
be like why did so many people see it
now i have a lot of empathy for the
context of this room in a localized
business if you're in denver you may not
need your views in new jersey
but
referral game friends of friends there's
a lot of real stuff going on in your
business that if you're thoughtful about
what i'm talking about you could take
advantage if you do a little legwork
early early facebook fan pages we're
talking about 10 years now
but the number of people whose first
post
get 5 10 15 000 views is remarkable it's
absolutely remarkable and i couldn't
compel you more to do it
not
because i'm a chinese spy
[Laughter]
i know
you cynics
not
because vaynermedia does well with tick
tock
but because
you have to
is she okay
she's good
i'm proud of you that was fast execution
do you need a job
but because i'm trying to get all of you
ready for the rest of your career let me
explain how many people here likes again
this is great i'm having fun
how many people here by show of hands
are retiring in the next 10 years and
before you raise it
i don't mean you're gonna crush it and
buy a yacht
i mean
you're old and you're finished
raise your hands 10 years raise it can i
get the likes please raise your hands 10
years
they are fair
okay thank you let's clap it up
we will let those 74 people slide for
this next sentence
for the rest of you
ten years
do you know how much technology changes
have happened last ten years
do you understand that almost everything
we do from i mean if you if you look at
your cliche 18 year old that lives on
two core things tick tock
and netflix they didn't even exist i
mean netflix did but in a very different
form cds to the house pretty cool
those two things didn't even exist and
this is where i need the ogs to hear to
go back to the history books with me
there are people in this room
my friends for the youngsters in here
under 30 under 30s make some noise
you're gonna like this one
under 30s there are people in this room
who once said that they would never get
a cell phone cause their pager was good
enough
let's go very vulnerable and honest by
show of hands
who in here was this person i'm never
getting an iphone the blackberry has
buttons and i need the buttons raise
your hands raise it high
by show of hands while we've got the
lights who in here said i'm never
getting either one of the following a
facebook a twitter an instagram and now
has one raise your hands raise them high
own it
my career
is completely predicated on one hyper
thesis
i have intuition from the luck of my
parents having sex at the right moment
that's true i have intuition
that allows me to understand what all of
you are gonna do when you think you're
not gonna do it
this is the crux of what i want to talk
about today with you both on the
marketing side as i've been and in a few
minutes on the management and team side
i need everybody here to leave today
with at least the seed of maybe kinda
sorta and i am not naive and incredibly
self-aware and very in tune to how this
may be entertaining and you might have
gotten a laugh and it might be curious
but you are viscerally against the
concept that i'm throwing down
as i said earlier that is incredibly
fine but let there be no confusion
the data
is extremely clear
market share amongst real estate agents
in local towns are shifting completely
predicated on the ability to be good at
social media
[Applause]
now
you may be more than happy with how much
you make
and have eight years seven years nine
years and you're like screw it if i make
a little bit less i'm still good and
that's amazing
that's actually awesome
do you
but if you're interested i mean it like
you know i i think people are very
confused at times like if you make 12 an
hour and you're pumped you won life
most of my millionaire friends are
miserable as [ __ ]
but if you have a sake or an interest in
growing market share in your place there
is nothing else this logo can do a lot
but not the thing we're talking about
you've got to make the content
you
you've got to talk about why your local
town is awesome i said this at a tom
ferry event i was here
10 years ago become the mayor of your
town with your content if you make
content of why this subway you know
burger shop is the best that might just
catch someone's eye and that becomes a
legion if you're the person that reviews
the school on video form in facebook
groups or on a tick tock that might be
the gateway drug to the business that
you're looking for content on social
has become a requirement of growth
not an option
it's clear
and again you don't need to do it but
it's really the conversation to be had
and i hope you guys take it a little
just a hair more serious and i hope
for the people that remember they did
well on facebook or instagram but then
the organic reach went down and you're
not doing as well for who here had a
good run with either facebook group or
instagram but then felt the effects of
the reach going down and are not doing
as well as they've done at their prime
time in their careers raise your hands
so for that group because you've already
tasted what i've talked about you must
immediately get serious about tick-tock
immediately yesterday
let's move on thank you for that chapter
of this talk
how many people here have employees
underneath them raise your hand
what have employees underneath them
people that work for them reason higher
people are so scared with hands
thank you
for that crowd and for the other crowd
but we're going to start with that crowd
there's something that i've been
spending a long time in my mind on but
it was back here it was in my
subconscious i didn't really i couldn't
get it all the way to the front
covid gave me an opportunity to get into
my feelings and
luckily i was able to finally get it
to the front you know that you know how
life works like we're all humans right
like it's there you know it's there and
finally oh damn it he's cancer get him
out of my life that stuff
that's what was gone sorry that was
that's where i'm about to go um
there's been something in my
here for the last 20 years that i just
couldn't figure out and i finally feel
comfortable and ready to talk about it
in a compelling way that makes the
argument
potentially land for all of you which is
why i wrote this book
i believe
that we have been
misguided in how to win in business
i believe that the popular
conversation of business
that we accept today as entrepreneurs
and operators
is wrong
i believe that
the dog eat dogs hard
elbows and my literally there may not be
a statement on earth that i hate more
and i don't like using the word hate but
there is not a statement on earth that i
hate more
than the concept of nice guys finish
last
if i could find the person that created
that saying
i would dig them up from the grab ground
and punch them in the neck
it is such
a fundamental misnomer
and i think it's time we have this
conversation
this book talks about leveraging the
emotional ingredients necessary for
business success
i don't believe any of us were raised
with the concept that the core tenant
for business success
is kindness
i just don't think that's something
we've ever heard
i don't think it's something people
believe
i even think when i just said it it was
like funny to say and funny to feel your
collective reaction
let there be no confusion about the next
part of this talk and where i'm going i
am not in the over coddling foofy foofy
like
world of business this is not about
entitlement i
the same person i want to dig up from
the great i want to destroy every human
associated with 8th place trophies
[Applause]
i am not looking to coddle this up
i'm here to dominate
i am here to build the single
greatest entrepreneurial career of all
time
i'm here to if you bother me too much
i'm going to start a real estate
brokerage in your local town and put you
out of business
i'm being dead serious i'm very weird
when it comes to competition
so as i talk about what i want to talk
about now please remember all the things
that i just said in the last two minutes
kindness
empathy
compassion
the soft skills
are actually the hard skills
people are confused
people are confused where we are
in the world not today this isn't about
i know where some of you are going to go
somebody's going to go oh i see what
gary's doing he's trying to prepare us
for gen z because they're so woke and
soft
[Laughter]
uh news alert that is not what i'm doing
what i'm trying to do is get everybody
prepared to understand how they can make
more money
how they can be more successful
how real this is
you have to understand what's happening
what's happening very simply is this
we've been lied to
the world is inherently abundant
even in a local business where you're
trying to compete against seven other
people that you know who you're
competing against for the houses the
fundamental truth is
nobody's taking yours you're limiting
your upside
the way you're limiting your upside is
over stressing about somebody else
getting a listing that you didn't get
when you spend two hours dwelling that
susan got it and you didn't
that's two hours that you played on
defense not offense
there's nobody taking your stuff
and because of that and things like that
we are confused we think that there's a
certain demeanor a certain style
that needs to be done for business
success of course
of course
you can be
massively financially successful
being atrocious
it exists
we know it and to me you know i heard
somebody say whether it's you know it is
unfortunate like honestly no feelings
towards it unfortunately fortunately it
is life
what's that got to do with you though
at the height
of the steve jobs
god era in silicon valley
i was booed
aggressively for the only time in my
career
ironically in this wonderful town
it's true i was on stage
in the height of steve jobs land at
south by southwest
and i proclaimed that i wanted to be
nothing like him
and that he stinks
because i didn't like the narrative that
i watched a lot of kids start running
their business because they heard that
steve was mean they decided to be me
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you